it's the substance butter mmm-hmm this
is funny
this was fun fried food is disgusting it
makes me feel gross it flows me down it
don't feel good when you eat crappy food
I'm nervous I'm excited I don't know if
my stomach is gonna agree it's funny
that we find this appetizing like at all
I have no idea what that is yeah that's
a strange shape this is a strange shape
I'm pretty unhappy about meaning it's a
video yeah all right this is fried pizza
I thought you didn't eat cheese I mean
dude I don't you like this whole video
is like a disaster it tastes like pizza
but this looks like chicken ma'am
I fill out bread yeah if you ordered a
pizza and got bread as a topping it
really get past the oily crunch but like
if Italian food were mixed with American
food fried and they had a happy baby I
think it would be this I was hoping that
peanut butter and jelly I love peanut
butter and jelly by itself
he's like Fear Factor damn I'm pretty
good I can hang with this 24/7 is it
like American french toast and came up
with this idea I want to find out we
should get this pad no I'm serious it
tastes better cuz it's fried little bit
I do feel a little bit of a sweat
forming
this is what the fair is like they fry
everything you could probably fry your
cousin if you wanted to ever there oh
this is harder to pull apart there we go
look at that that looks fun Pleasant
yeah I work with this this one's good
this works better because it's just like
owning the fact that this is terrible
it's not like mixing weird it's just
like junk food upon junk food and okay I
ever done with that one though
[Music]
it's literally a stick of butter why
would you eat fried butter uh people
don't do that right people do that oh
god this is so greasy one two nope nope
yep
that means clay see James is not gonna
be tasting this thing guys I think my
mind's playing tricks on me it tastes
like a sugar cookie but I know it's full
butter and I know my heart slowing down
because of it sir would be good with
this oh I'm like gagging for you oh wow
Yolo that's pretty horrible I kind of
don't mind it
yeah I'm fighting the stronger is to
take a nap right now I just hope that
people don't eat fried butter on the
regulator that makes me sad
yeah the butter is gonna keep me eating
healthy for the next week or so at least
just to make up for the hutt yeah my
views has not changed for this video at
all now I just have to do a couple of do
some running to get all this crap out of
my system I mean don't get me wrong I'm
very adventurous but a stick of butter
is a little too much just a little too
much I definitely still feel my
convictions against fried food I'm not
gonna give in but it was nice to taste
it again I never just ate butter before
it was so like fried butter was just an
act I guess the next step we were so
unnecessary in my life